[Music]
radiate boundless love towards the
entire
world a disciplined mind brings
happiness give even if you have only a
little conquer anger with love conquer
Badness with goodness conquer meanness
with generosity
conquer dishonesty with
truth drop by drop the water pot is
filled likewise the wise man Gathering
little by little fills himself with
good I will not look on another's Bowl
intent of finding fault a training to be
observed Delight in heedful
guard well your
thoughts should you find a wise critic
to point out your faults follow him as
you would a guide to Hidden
Treasure should a Seeker not find a
companion who is better or equal let him
resolutely pursue a solitary
course in whom there is no sympathy for
living being beings know him as an
outcast hatred is Never appeased by
hatred In This World by non-h hatred
alone is hatred appeased this is a law
Eternal live with no sense of mind not
forming attachment to
experiences all conditioned things are
impermanent when one sees this with
wisdom One turns away from
suffering ardently do today what must be
done who knows tomorrow death may
come to support mother and father to
cherish wife and children and to be
engaged in peaceful occupation this is
the greatest
blessing all tremble at violence all
fear death putting oneself in the place
of another one should not kill or cause
another to
kill they blame those who remain silent
they blame those who speak much they
blame those who speak in moderation
there is none in this world who is not
blamed just as the great ocean has one
taste the taste of salt so also this
teaching and discipline has one taste
the taste of
Liberation if with a pure mind a person
speaks or acts happiness follows them
like a never departing
Shadow as an elephant in the battlefield
withstands arrows shot from bows all
around even so shall I Endure
abuse
the root of suffering is attachment
whatever precious Jewel there is in the
Heavenly worlds there is nothing
comparable to one who is
awakened it is in the nature of things
that Joy arises in a person free from
[Music]
remorse Purity and impurity depend on
oneself no one can purify
another
ceasing to do evil cultivating the good
purifying the heart this is the teaching
of the
Buddhas understanding is the Heartwood
of Wells spoken
words just as a solid rock is not shaken
by the storm even so the wise are not
affected by Praise or
blame
we will develop love we will practice it
we will make it both a way and a
basis there is no fear for one whose
mind is not filled with
[Music]
desire whatever is not yours let go of
it your letting go of it will be for
your long-term happiness and
benefit meditate
do not delay lest you later regret
it whatever can arise can
[Music]
cease your own self is your master who
else could be with yourself well
controlled you gain a master very hard
to
[Music]
find your work is to discover your work
and then with all your heart to give
yourself to
it I do not dispute with the world
rather it is the world that disputes
with
me you cannot travel the path until you
have become the path
itself do not dwell in the past do not
dream of the future concentrate the mind
on the present
moment
if we could see clearly the miracle of a
single flower our whole life would
change the only real failure in life is
not to be true to the best one
[Music]
knows be truthful do not yield to anger
give freely even if you have but little
the gods will bless
you
the whole secret of existence is to have
no fear never fear what will become of
you depend on no one only at the moment
you reject all help are you
[Music]
free if anything is worth doing it is
worth doing with all your
heart when you attain victory over
yourself not even the gods can turn it
into defeat
[Music]
better than a thousand Hollow words is
one word that brings
[Music]
peace what we think we
become if you do not change direction
you may end up where you are
heading nothing can harm you as much as
your own unguarded thoughts
nothing remains without
change one moment can change your day
one day can change your life one life
can change a
world faith and prayer are invisible but
they make impossible things
possible with mindfulness strive
on if the problem can be solved why
worry if the problem cannot be solved
worrying will not help you solve
it you must love yourself before you
love another by accepting yourself and
fully being who you are your simple
presence can make others
[Music]
happy everything that happens to us is
the result of what we ourselves have
thought said or done we alone are
responsible for our
lives love the whole world as a mother
loves her only
child health is the greatest gift
contentment is the greatest
[Music]
wealth it is better to do nothing than
to do what is wrong whatever you do you
do to
[Music]
yourself work out your own salvation do
not depend on
others do not look for a sanctuary in
anyone but
yourself no one saves us but ourselves
no one can and no one may we ourselves
must walk the
path
if we fail to look after others when
they need help who will look after
us one who acts on truth is happy in
this world and
Beyond wear your ego like a loosefitting
[Music]
garment when watching after yourself you
watch after others when watching after
others you watch after
yourself the greatest gift is to give
people your Enlightenment to share
it ambition is like love impatient both
of delays and of
Rivals you as much as anybody in the
entire universe deserve your love and
[Music]
affection if you propose to speak always
ask yourself is it true is it necessary
is it
[Music]
kind every human being is the author of
his own health or
disease the tongue like a sharp knife
kills without drawing
blood the way is not in the sky it is in
the
heart if you truly loved yourself you
would never hurt
another every morning we are born again
what we do today is what matters
most nothing ever exists entirely alone
everything is related to everything
else
that